Allen is in Nebraska hi Colin welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave and Rachel
thank you so much for taking my call
today sure how can we help so I received
a call earlier this week that my
position at my employer had been
eliminated and of course it's coming
during what seems like the worst
possible time I'm not freaking out but
I'm beginning to be a little realistic
about what's going on my backgrounds and
journalism and public relations and so
I've been looking at different
opportunities related to that what I've
quickly learned is that basically
everyone's on a higher increase and so
I'm looking at different options outside
of that because I like working and I
know what I'm hitting you know all the
right now same exactly yeah I'm just
trying to figure out the best balance
I'm really looking at everything and I'm
willing to try anything new and so I'm
just trying to figure out the best
balance between I don't want to just sit
around waiting for the right position or
the perfect one to come along I want to
be able to you know make myself useful
so I guess what says what are you making
what are you making are you making at
your current job fifty-thousand okay and
you're single
yes okay and how much notice are they
giving you you've done already or next
week
it was the day of on Monday so I'm done
so I've been spending the week applying
around and I have a couple interviews
lined up and so you have any money
instead of Inchon all over I have my
basic emergency fund and then I put the
I pump the brakes recently just because
I kind of saw this coming
and so basically between my severance
and I'll be having coming in soon I'm
not panicking at the moment I've got I
figured out that I'd be fine for at
least a few months but how much how much
money you got with all that probably
about about $5,000 and you can make it
two months on that yeah okay good good
so you're already doing good analysis
that's very good because what that does
is it it takes all that I mean no
because when you get that somebody just
walks and goes you're done today that's
like getting hit by car I mean you know
I just right you go into freakout mode
normal humans do anyway and you
immediately
you immediately started doing critical
thinking and said okay I got this I got
this I can make it to month so I can
just chill out I'm already starting by
Friday I've already got interviews lined
up man you're on fire you're doing great
I'm proud of you
so yeah I appreciate that we're who are
the interviews with what type of
companies on media so for publicity no
not at the moment those are not I've
applied to some of those are not
available once with a credit union
working in customer service and then
there's another company where I'd be
doing like administrative work and so
I'm kind of looking all over yeah that's
very very wise because they're you know
your worst case scenario is you know you
take a job at Amazon and delivering
pizzas or something like that because
they're hiring like crazy all those
people are worried and that's just but
you don't have to worry about that today
so you you've got a two month time frame
to not go completely - I'll do whatever
I have to do for a version of this right
you can get there so hey jump on Ken
Coleman's website and download all of
those resume templates hold on I'll give
you a copy of this book if you don't
already have it proximity principle
because you are in hike in Coleman mode
right now you know get a job get a job
and his resume templates his process to
getting in the door is bar none the best
I've ever seen and so he can really help
you with that